here morning
folks that's what I forgot
ready to go here so um I really want to
have this update ready like this
week um few things I need for
that okay monitoring a couple messages
on the side here but um we're in pretty
decent shape so
docks are
here um the main thing I don't know what
the heck is wrong with Discord lately
that their Banner doesn't
work um main thing that we need for this
release got our new
homepage we've got
ocean see all these new
environments two three four five six
seven eight nine new environments this
doesn't have a baseline yet
um yeah this doesn't have a baseline yet
this doesn't have a baseline yet this
doesn't have a baseline yet uh and then
Enduro from bet uh also needs to be
added with Baseline plus I have one
other environment that I'm working on
that's taking a ton of time as well
which is what I'm generally working on
off
stream
um order of priorities
here highest priority is going to be
getting at least these two plus Enduro
which is bets M I want those all on here
working working
well I got to figure out with this one
this one's potentially going to be
harder to deal
with
which let me just double check with
Nathan
okay sent Nathan a quick check up um for
this end this end is really cool it just
needs like a few small tweaks
right MOA is good to
go it's got a decent Baseline on it and
everything and then I think that the
only other things that we really need
outside of this are we need to make sure
that paper build cleanly doesn't have
any weird install bugs uh and that the
traditional third party M's are still
working fine for it as
well uh docs generally pretty
decent single page has everything you
need on
it I got to fix like a few small
formatting things here and there but
like all the work is done for this so I
think what we're going to do now is I'm
going to just look at some of the
existing Ms and make sure that
everything still works as
expected let's
try yeah let's try a few
things I'm going to just get a new
camera
this one's just kind of
bad okay so the most important ones are
probably just Atari what a lot of people
people
runs perfect so we get this
error that's actually what we want
I know what I'm doing so I'm going to
set ve over
work and I believe this should still
train at a reasonable
speed oh yeah look at that 27 28,000
steps per second
and then we will
see three minute train run to test the
tar is not bad
for reference here I have not touched I
have not touched this environment in
months so it's still looking like it
works is good
and there it goes long is an M that
trains very very quickly once it get
started
so I mean we haven't tuned this like at
all um and I've had no idea what changes
I've made to puffer but it looks
like uh our parameters
bad oh there it goes 20 score in uh in
two
pong in 2 minutes is
solid our version of pong trains much
faster than that as
so Al Works mini grid I think
next I've heard I got reports of
something not working with minig grid
minig grid is an important end
okay we're not going to do like all new
hyper pram sweeps for Atari and stuff uh
we're going to keep the ones we had
which still should be just about the
same as before maybe we've changed a few
small implementation things here and
there uh since they were tuned but no
big deal I think in
particular uh since since these were
tuned I believe I changed the Atari
wrappers a little bit so things are
going to vary just a bit no big deal
though okay now let's try mini grid
slow
ah I see
policy Let's uh let's figure out what's
wrong with
this get something training real quick
for
okay so I don't actually know what
the problem should be
here this does seem to be a legitimate
issue though
faster see how much faster puffer Li
is you know a stupid W be in the loop
being solved
right
85 yeah there you
here that's
fixed what
else M agent we know is
screwy let's at least try to get
[Music]
proj I don't think M agent's going to
work it's and that's there that's on
them that their code's just
screwy we technically have The Binding
but they've got to fix some stuff if
they want that to be used I don't think
they
will Cen Big
Fish okay so this is kind of a
growth warning here
this does
[Music]
train bottleneck entirely by
policy makes sense
prop gen MMS are cool
um they're a little bit too slow for me
to really want to invest too heavily in
them but for 200,000 steps per second
that's probably the best like pixel
render end that there
is it does train
well also
[Music]
runs
crafter I hate this
environment I should add uh the new
version but it depends on ja which is
annoying
bad look at this 84% of your time is
just spent waiting on the stupid
environment this is how slow it is
trains like a couple thousand steps per
second terrible
code uh I think GPU drive has external
depths right
here they've got their own container
though I think they're
work I would like to fix Gridley
potentially bamford's awesome and I wish
his project got more love
I'll give it a few seconds to see if it
actually works um I know that they have
it working with puffer lib in their own
repo anyways and they're like actively
maintaining it so I'm not going to make
it be you know the puffer fork for where
you use it they already have
look if you look at
this we actually we made their Baseline
10x faster Puffer
and Dy put the puffer that's
good yeah they took my recommendations
for everything here as well this is this
is exactly what you want to do
job uh clearly I don't have it set up
properly for local Dev but that's not
really an issue
spiders
Le
huh emerged some stuff from
uh from David like eight months ago
that's funny
first he hasn't shipped any
new packages it looks
like that's annoying
oh I'll have to send Chris the uh the
new ocean puffer
yeah this part's really good
ra live integration is
rib doesn't look like anything has been
solved
I'm just going to add a warning I think
to it
think
[Music]
uhuh yeah that's weird that could be a
python version thing or whatever
whatever I mean this would be a really
nice m to have though to be
fair but you don't actually get 70k I
know at a
fine and we fixed mini grid we contested
the other common ones good
enough yeah all these other these
work I kind of want to go fix these
docks real fast as well
okay it's a couple small things improved
[Music]
I where did I screw this
up for
ocean somewhere after
so policies
import
strong uh where's the bug
here which codes oh slash
uh perfect now our docks are
good everything
renders per
um I think I pinned that hack already
right yeah 0.9.1 this is fine
we will have to build a new
container uh at some point but that's no
big
deal what about like classic
control cart
sanity Aloha starting the live coding
Alliance website will be up next
month sharing
ship not really sure what that is
about uh this is the stuff I do is high
performance reinforcement learning Dev
for the most
part gymnasium
Pap okay that's a problem cull should
definitely work um
ah okay yeah that's a problem I need to
add a a warning on that for
oh right I don't actually use native
anymore
there we
go I think that's
better one last thing for users to shoot
themselves in the foot
width uh and I don't actually know if I
use native anywhere at all do
I I don't actually think I do anymore
if I just delete this does everything
still
work pretty sure it does
good okay there's cart Pole
very nice
play and then we do for
fast yeah this is a 30 second solve
right
second okay we've utterly failed because
it's a
uh whatever this is 35 second
solve um that's fine
this is
good
M sanity
M I wonder what a typical day in your
life looks
like
um get up at
6 hits news get up at like 610 or
620 uh get coffee go run do like between
two and four hours of work either on
stream or off stream go lift weights for
an hour go get brunch come back do work
until dinner time again either on stream
or off stream get dinner uh at like
early like 5 or 6 the
latest uh read something or do whatever
for like an hour sometimes I have
meetings or experiments to check stuff
like that go to bed that's about it
the uh the work hours really are not
that crazy but it is very it is very
structured around me being able to like
have my head in the right spot for all
of
it there's like very little room for
distraction and like know not getting
good days
in forgot to mention the Thousand
calorie breakfast mug
I think that we're going to punt on
these just a little
bit so we have these sandym and they're
really
important and we need them to work but I
like bet had afforded these to to scon
they're going to go to C eventually uh
there's a lot of stuff I want to do with
these but this is going to be really
part of the science Arc yeah technically
building environments but they're like
really simple um specifically
constructed single purpose environments
so oan
go I've been trying to like get my
schedule to be even more structured and
disciplined it's very very difficult
especially when working around Hard
Exercise like I tend to just randomly
lose an hour somehow like after like
just around having a hard of exercise
just from like moving slowly being
fatigued that kind of a thing so I've
been trying to figure out how to reclaim
a couple extra hours for work a day but
it is quite tricky to really really
oh we should just prefix it with puffer
right
yeah so this will just be puffer
Bandit puffer yeah we definitely want
these fixs for release good thing I did
this uh it's actually pretty good though
this
is like there's nowhere near as much
Jank as I was afraid I've actually kept
the repository pretty darn clean
throughout this update and there's
really not a lot of
Jank like there's not like usually
there's just a bunch of weird stuff that
doesn't work in between updates but this
has been pretty uh pretty good and
solid well that was fast
um hold
what I don't think I'm seeing the last
print out
here yeah we're not seeing the last
print
go and again these have not been tuned
like at all so go to
50k just to make sure it actually
trains this totally trains we're good
solves the
Bandit let me just uh make sure that all
these
regardless I did password already didn't
I
good does this do
anything yeah this is this is like an
old test that shouldn't be in the sanity
checks puff for Li will solve Arc
prize I
mean that's like a thing that's heavily
reliant on human
intuition is the issue with that like
the arc prize I don't think it can be
solved from first principles that's the
problem with it like you can't just do
five or 10 or like even a hundred of
them and then know how to do all the
others from scratch like it's probably
actually impossible to do that doesn't
mean it's a hard problem it just means
it's very grounded in human
intuition
um I don't know I would fa
like the like the AR prize is not AGI at
all either it's going to be like solved
and then big deal and like everything's
going to move on um something like net
hack net hack is a way way better eval
for like okay you literally just made
general intelligence
work yeah this works okay so this
is these ones are very
good uh we now have this is working
perfectly fine here
we don't have sanity Ms on
here puffer Li plus brain orino Farm
whatever that
means I just want to solve reinforcement
learning we're going to be in a very
very good spot actually um this is this
update is going to be out with within
the next couple of weeks it has to be
because otherwise we're going to get
swamped by tons of
announcements um and then I think that
with this update we are actually set up
to fix the whole field of reinforcement
learning in the next year because if you
think about it right like we now have
environments that run a thousand times
faster than everyone else's and that
train at tens of billions of steps per
day per
GPU so we're just going to be able to
run thousands of experiments like we
don't even have to be smart at all what
we're going to do is we're just going to
like look at all the things that looked
kind of promising over the last 10 years
of ourl history and we're just going to
run really comprehensive experiments and
just build up you know algorithmic
improvements until orala is a stable and
sane field that doesn't feel janky and
cursed that's all it's going to be like
there's probably not even going to be
anything particularly genius coming out
of it right it's probably going to be
like a pretty small set of algorithmic
tweaks um and like training setup
changes and stuff like that and then RL
is just going to suddenly be reasonable
and sane and
stable that's the
plan oh I need to add docks for these
that's important I forgot to add docks
for
these I also should check if I have like
random readme
this yeah these aren't really that big
of a deal nobody really uses
this I basically kind of figured that
with puffer lib the way that I'm going
to prioritize stuff I used to kind of
just like try to do everything and like
you know make sure we have every feature
and make sure that you know puffer's
just good in every possible way and that
just doesn't work when you're developing
as an individual for the most part so
what I do now is I develop towards the
set of Fe features that I will
personally need in order to make
reinforcement learning a sane and stable
field I prioritize what I will
personally need for that and then if I
have like a collab with an academic
group and they need a feature I'll add
that for them and then if I have uh you
know a company that wants something then
they can buy a support package and then
I can prioritize that but this is just
like a much easier way to handle
okay so this is good I put tons of
comments here is there discussion this
number's gotten
bigger did he like reply to some of
these or
something okay so he started
like cool he's like started to work on
these and is like replying to check them
out that's cool
uh for folks watching there's I did a
stream yesterday I did a 1H hour long
code review of this entire what is this
like a thousand line PR or something
yeah I did a one hour long review of
this entire thousand long PR thousand
long line PR I gave like 40 comments
live and wrote down here um it's a
really like a bunch of good feedback for
new people in
RL um so if you're interested in just
getting into RL this is a really good
way to do it just come up with a cool en
idea um run it by me say like hey is
this a useful rln probably yes and then
get it on to the website like just the
whole process of contributing an m is a
really good way to learn stuff and I
review all contributions of that sort
live this is how a lot of them have come
about
actually like I built the Moa and I
built snake and then there's one other
Enon here that's not listed yet plus I
built these two prototypes but then like
uh this was Nathan this was Noah this
was Nathan uh these four were Spencer
there's one coming from BET with Enduro
there's one coming from Xander with
trash pickup uh Noah's looking at tcg
now so lots of people building stuff
really good way to
learn only requirement for getting good
feedback is that you uh you know
contribute open source code so we can
host these Ms and actually use them for
research all the code and puffers open
source MIT
licensed okay so this is what I was
missing here I need to
okay so this is I need to change this
file first of all because that's no
longer
true this really doesn't need a read me
MD
we have all the docs are just going to
be on the website it's way easier that
way oh and then this is yeah there's
just s. High
cool uh so I'm going to have to
copy from the current docs I think
get
progress I just add
actually I
had whatever I had on that GitHub was
pretty good for
that all just combobulated right now
hold
on I know what I'm trying to do I'm just
things are not
and I need to include
this
image I'm going to
quick yeah I'm not ashamed to uh admit I
literally don't know how to add freaking
image in
Ed image HTML
all
now we go
to
and I'll just put I'll put the work in
progress grid
above above
points and I think I have docks on
these I can just
copy yeah so this is one where you would
kind of want to get the dock string
okay so what should I actually do here
um I've got a little bit of an
annoyance
where I really wanted to make like the
majority of the docks of puffer just be
a
tutorial so like right now in the new
one where is it so in the new offer here
if you check docs it's a onepage
tutorial in this onepage tutorial the
idea is it covers everything you need it
has like full Snippets that you can just
copy paste if you forget stuff it tells
you how to do everything it explains
everything it's like a quick read it
takes you through everything right um
and then you don't have to go clicking
around a big reference when really it's
a pretty small Library um but then like
for environment specific
Al you kind of want to have docks for
each
kind and I want them to be on the
website I don't want to have to have
like readme MDS or whatever with the
code in the source I want them to just
be on the
website I mean you kind of do want it to
be built from the dock strings
I think I'll just put more hey man when
are you planning to release oh I just
saw that Nathan uh the goal is before NS
Nathan so
ideally um not this coming Monday but
the Monday after
ideal that might even be too late
really want to get this thing out as
soon as I
can and that timing will be really good
because then
um you know I'll be able like I'll take
a couple days to think through some
stuff and it'll be the holidays and then
basically we're going to hit the ground
running in
2025 um
with like really heavy science side
stuff on how we're going to fix
reinforcement learning using all these
environments
and it's going to be very fast it's
going to be very
exciting hopefully you're still here and
saw that and heard that
yeah that's cool good yeah I don't know
how much time you have lately but look
if you can even get like a just like a
simple-ish training demo for this
tactics M where like there's a curve
that goes up and the Agents kind of do
something like like it doesn't have to
be perfect right it's just we want these
to be usable as
M's busy with defense and moving but I
can
finish for next week yeah okay that'd be
awesome oh yeah yeah I forgot that
you're doing uh you got your defense to
do yeah best of luck with that
um I know mine's on YouTube it did
pretty well if you want to watch that um
let me think for
defense it took me a while to figure
out how to do stuff with
that I definitely focused way more time
on making sure like I didn't spend a ton
of time on slides I spent a lot of time
on the delivery and making sure that the
sequencing of what I was saying and
everything was going to be good I
generally I spend very little time on
like slides and making like the content
look professional I spend a lot of time
on making sure the delivery is good it
really doesn't matter what the hell you
have on the slides uh if the delivery is
good and if you have good slides but the
delivery is bad then that's kind of
worthless
it took like probably three weeks to
prepare my defense
talk I spent very little time on the
manuscript I spent like less than a week
on my manuscript it's just pasting
together a bunch of
papers Dark theme
slides I mean mine are mine are on the
YouTube guess as well like
um I do all my stuff in like the puffer
teal color now it's been
good but yeah like literally um I find
people tend to spend way too much time
on like making professional slides cuz
it's like the comfortable thing I don't
know like I have not like talked with
you personally right U most researchers
I know especially in my lab at MIT
people had like way better slides uh
than me and but they put like no effort
whatsoever into the delivery of it you
know they would give like very dry
boring rambly academic talks they give
like a lot of their talks they're like
random lab talks they give seated which
is nuts
right so really thinking about
delivery is
good and you don't need to get all the
details either right you can get like
everything you say should be correct but
if you leave specific details out that's
totally fine you just are ready to
answer
them what are good delivery advice I
mean watch the best thing I can show you
is to watch my thesis defense on YouTube
I mean I don't know here that did pretty
darn well for a reason right
content yeah so this thing has over
160,000 views
right so I mean like basically every
single thing in this defense that I did
it comes off pretty natural at least
decently natural um but like every
single thing here is practiced I spent
like multiple weeks going through I
probably gave this like did a pract like
practice for this I probably went
through this thing like a 100 times
um that's really what that takes to do
I'm not like a naturally good speaker or
anything it's just I put a lot of work
into it
right like I'm naturally a lot more like
I don't really I wouldn't say I'm
naturally quiet but I'm generally very
happy not having to do a bunch of like
know out there social stuff um but you
know you can definitely do this type of
a thing regardless of where you stand
there
um tux is optional I just did it for
fun I thought it would be
amusing um yeah you can see like a lot
of these slides it's just like an image
and then like a few bullet points not a
lot of text I try not to do anything
that's going to take the focus off of me
I had a couple blank slides in there
where I just wanted to talk about
something for a minute or two
right this is just how I've done all my
stuff for a long time there's like an
image maybe there's like a piece of code
there's like a
title it's very much on you to just do
the delivery of it so like that like the
narrative went through multiple drafts
right I practiced the delivery as I went
through it to see if it flowed
well all that stuff and then though it
didn't do as well probably because it
wasn't like a thesis defense I thought I
did quite well with my Iceberg video as
well cuz this one wasn't this one was a
segmented
talk um so I didn't have to do the whole
thing in one take so I could really
rehearse and like I could really plan
everything out so like basically every
single move and gesture is planned here
um and it's just like I went through it
enough times for it to not to be like
robotic and like I know exactly where
every single image is going to be on the
slide so like
literally like I'm not looking at
anything right these like these are
green screened
on
right
here where's this
thing so like I know that this is going
to be here literally
and like I'm looking back and forth at
stuff that I know is going to be there
yeah this this video
thumbnail yeah game I guess I I mean I
went like the iceberg style was kind of
the clickbait thing here it was nowhere
near as effective you know algorithm
but yeah that's what I can tell you for
the most
part I did like a lot of stuff to get
better at presenting over the years I
did like so so so many things to get
better at
that because I used to be a God awful
presenter
yeah I got some funny stories about that
as well but that'll be for another
tutorial simple example of how to run
the carb sweep would be nice too if you
don't have that already we have that
it's literally one
command and then uh in the container um
carbs repo will be
yeah so we just have lots of commands
and stuff by the way this is live um
it's just puffer AI GitHub ipuff for.
you can access all the docs like all the
beta stuff is
think that's everything right all multi-
agent
funny I didn't even consider putting
something like that
in uh in a tutorial CU it's like
basic command prompt like it's basic CLI
stuff but
sure
oops Yeah I forget a lot of science
folks are like I the thing is like I
forget that cuz I really don't use a ton
of fancy things so I kind of figure if I
know it probably everyone knows it but
no most people are way heavier science
side no HTML
image I mean you did submit a pretty
darn nice CPR so you get
is
there no dash dash basel's a
thing oh wait this is yeah this one is
wrong good call
look I love this snake environment so
much it's the first one I made and it's
just it's so
nice just like look at this
thing isn't it
cool it looks even cooler if you run it
with like a ton of snakes but then it's
like you can't really tell what's going
on it just turns into abstract art
spaces yeah except that it requires
running a freaking neural network for
every know for all the agent forward
passes
voids with their
logic I've actually wanted to have a
voids
implementation um like a neural boids
implementation for a while if anybody
wants to add one that would kind of be a
cool continuous M to have I'm kind of
jealous of Sak's website
stand they get rid of
it I know David
ha has
website oh yeah look he has you can play
this
game this is pretty cool you can just
take over for it as well and if you
don't press anything for a second uh the
neuronet will start
playing this is really
cool I've wanted to do this for a while
as well I mean we could probably like
Port this
stuff oh I forgot that he was on Palmer
man as well yeah David H really is one
of those researchers who has a lot of
cool
work but I was trying to find he has a
cool implementation of like voids
somewhere I he used to maybe he got rid
of
cool so that's a bunch of small
fixes I'm feeling uh pretty good about
the release now that was a lot of the
Jank um for folks watching this so this
is um you know
Public public call for testing and stuff
um my goal is to release this within 2
weeks uh I've been working on this for a
very long time really easy way to help
out with that even if you don't have a
ton of time is just download puffer like
you know try out the dev branch and play
around with it for a bit and anytime you
hit like hey this doesn't make sense
this is unintuitive this gives me a
weird error just post it in the Discord
or bring it up on stream I mean that's
pretty much all it takes in order to get
something really polished is to have
your users actually tell you every time
something weird
happens that's pretty much all it
takes is this online
yet I don't know what's wrong with this
Discord Banner
flag I think just the service behind it
gone down for a
ocean yep here we go everything's
online very
nice RL Game Dev is the dream job it's
freaking hard work a lot of it is
freaking hard
work you have all the Jank of RL and all
the Jank of Game Dev
and you have to do everything like a THX
performance yeah it's good
though we're going to start doing more
science side stuff
soon I also wish we could get somebody
to like help finish this end just cuz
this end is like so cool this is uh Robo
code it's like this old tank battling
game so I'm playing the blue one now and
stuff oh that's what I should add I
should add dock strings to all of these
yeah let me do that right now
actually that's a good thing to
do train device CPU on
map I
see got to Ria thank
you me try that real
and that's one other small
fix and then I think we go from there we
go to
docks and we oops not
there
and then there are a couple other
contributors I need to
add was this David no this
was Jade
credit there we go and hopefully I
didn't M any Miss anybody
here I think I got the main
right oh no wait it's up
down oh know it works
ad to turn and W to
move ad to turn
that at least add a little bit of
context I'd
right a there it goes wait not all of
them though oh it must just be
very
solid very solid indeed
we got our blog we got the
docs docs should be
clean
good okay I think that's good shape um
that is those are all like just the
minor tweaks I wanted to fix this
morning we went through all the third
party Ms we made sure the main the ones
that people actually commonly use care
about
work um maoko
there so I think we are
oops Dam
yeah that's just Nathan okay we're good
so I think that's everything I wanted to
get done for the morning that's like a
bunch of just good little cleanup stuff
for um for puffer lib again please just
go ahead download it try it out let me
know on the Discord if stuff doesn't
work I'm mostly just going to be playing
around with stuff and tweaking things
like this for the next few days while I
work on uh Baseline for the last few M
that haven't come in yet and then likely
I'm going to try to get like a updated
container like updated image build ready
for uh for next
week and then after that uh I'm probably
going to spend a few days just making
like a little bit of promo
material uh getting the announcements
ready stuff like that and then it'll
launch and then we'll get to do new cool
stuff from there so great time to jump
in if you're interested in doing any of
this work um you can find more of my
stuff
on X Twitter
whatever jars
here it's all just RL content I also
have lots of Articles including like
this how to get started in reinforcement
learning whole bunch of stuff on
AI very occasional off topic Fitness
Post but mostly just AI
uh you can check the Discord and other
than that I'm streaming most of the dev
so thanks folks I'll be back probably
later this afternoon for at least a good
few hours um